This programming assignment was a way for you to practice creating scatter
plots, and to make sure that you knew how to work with our
new data frame. We'll use our GG plot function to get our
histogram, and we'll pass it the two variables that we had in our
data frame, age and friend count mean. And for the data variable,
I want to pass it PF.FC by age, instead of PF, since this
was the new data frame we're working with. Writing this code I
see that I get an error, and that's because I forgot my geom.
I needed to add geom point. So adding that as
another layer, I can run my code and get the result.
Now we can do slightly better than this plot. Let's
connect our dots in order of age by using geom line
instead of geom point. This plot immediately makes clear the
patterns we mentioned before, as well as the oddness at age
69. We see that through the older ages, our estimates
are highly variable for friend count mean. They're jumping up and
down, sort of all over the place. And
for our young users, they still have high friend
counts, and for the ages between 30 and 60,
the mean count is hovering just about over 100.